the White House is in damage control
this morning over the news that
President Trump reimburse attorney
Michael Cohen for the 130,000 dollars he
paid stormy Daniels the president
acknowledged the repayment yesterday he
denied that campaign money was used in
the effort to silence the adult film
star who he says had an affair with mr.
Trump White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders deflected reporters questions
about mr. Trump's previous claim that he
didn't know about the payment weecha
Jang is at the White House with the
latest we took good morning good morning
bianna Rudy Giuliani has only been part
of President trumps legal team for two
weeks but in the past 36 hours he's
become the de facto spokesman providing
sometimes conflicting details about
stormy Daniels North Korea and the
Russia investigation many of which
caught White House officials off-guard
as the president celebrated the National
Day of Prayer at the White House what a
day what a beautiful day and our country
is doing very well his new legal
mouthpiece Rudy Giuliani continued his
media campaign about the president's
repayment to Michael Cohen he didn't
know the details of this until we know
the details of it while the White House
insisted mr. Trump was initially in the
dark when Cohen paid stormy Daniels this
was information that the president
didn't know at the time but eventually
learned White House press secretary
Sarah Huckabee Sanders did not clarify
when the president found out he was
reimbursing Cohen for the $130,000
payment to the adult film star but echo
Giuliani's claimed that it was after the
fact the president reimbursed a-- on
March 7th Sanders said the President did
not know about the payments there was no
knowledge of any payments from the
president yesterday reporters asked
whether she had lied I've given the best
information I had at the time on the
Russia probe Giuliani spent the day
trashing the Muller investigation
telling CBS News I want the Justice
Department to close this thing down
they don't have a scintilla of evidence
but he also said the president could
still sit for an interview with Moeller
under the right conditions former
assistant US attorney Kim Whaley
was part of Kenneth's stars team on the
Whitewater investigation into President
Clinton she said mr. Trump's new lawyer
Emmett flood who defended Bill Clinton
may want to avoid an interview
I think mr. flood has a formidable
charge in front of him in terms of
representing mr. Trump through an
interview under oath because there is no
way I think for him to answer those
questions and avoid potential additional
liability Oh former Trump campaign aide
Michael Caputo who has been interviewed
by Muller's investigators told CBS News
it was quote spooky how much they knew
about the Trump campaign and how it
worked he said it was an intimidating
experience beyond a-- we should thank
you